okay so if you've been paying attention
to Twitter reddit lately you've probably
heard about this Jenner's the popular
just chatting streamer first was accused
of sexual misconduct by viewers and then
had hundreds of discord messages leaked
that allegedly showed her using racist
sexist anti-semitic and transphobic
language this story is obviously really
messy so let me break it down for you
okay so this is Jeff
she's been streaming on Twitch since
2014 started out as a runescape streamer
and has recently become popular in the
gist chatting section but Gina's
people.you fuller
not BAM it's empty she often streams to
have more than 2,000 viewers at a time
she's also a staple of the Raj Patel
show at which talk show that brings
together some of the most honest and
well let's say uncensored personalities
on Twitch to discuss a variety of topics
that are almost always controversial now
all this news on reddit with Jenna
started on Tuesday January 7th when
Jenna told a story on stream of an
interaction she'd had with a friend in
years past
now obviously the story balloons into
something even crazier but in order for
you to understand that I want to take
you back to where it started basically
Jenna tried to kiss her friend and then
when he declined
she said she'd make fun of him to her
twitch chat for not kissing her back and
he said this is weird and denied me to
which I then went on to roast him for 20
minutes straight about how I was gonna
go to my livestream and tell everyone
that I tried to kiss him and he told me
this is weird
too where the he then went on to kiss me
and I got my way the situation blew up
pretty quickly and many people were
reacting to this footage with claims of
sexual misconduct and yeah that clip
sounds really bad but like most things
on the Internet
it turned out to not be the whole story
there's a lot more context and some of
it made this seem a little less of the
year but some of it also made it seem
even worse in order to better explain
the entire story Jenna jumped on another
stream to provide more details of what
happened yeah told me later on because I
asked him like why did you say this is
weird because he'd been making this on
me for a while and I'd been shutting him
down
and he said it was cuz he was shocked
cuz he thought he was friendzone
and he didn't know like he just was
shocked
I literally still talk to the student to
this day he's my best friend and she
also brought the alleged victim onto her
stream so he could explain his side of
things did i coerce you into kissing you
what you didn't want nope did you want
to kiss me yep had I friendzone you
previously and denied your advances yep
the situation then continued to expand
when the subject was brought up on the
January 12th edition of the Raj Patel
show Jenna jumped into a conversation
with Raj streamer's Nia mal Kovac
Knut IVA una love and destiny to further
discuss the incident after a lot of
back-and-forth the cast decided that
although the original clips seemed like
Jenna had forced herself on someone
after the additional context was
provided it wasn't that simple but
there's a lot of context but I but I
think what he's the problem that destiny
has is just because like you're making
all these assumptions in your particular
like situation it's probably it's fine
it works right with your particular
situation but it's not necessarily
consistent across all situations with
that said they also agreed that using
somebody's twitchchat to pressure
someone is not a good look and at the
very least not a good way to treat your
friend right shrink people into like
doing things is actually whatever even
if it's as a joke I just I don't think
okay pressuring people into physical
things even as a joke I just don't think
that's very cool with that in mind we
all know how these stories can take on a
life of their own after they blow up on
the street and streamer Eva Luna loved
made that point really clear during the
conversation yes I absolutely agree that
this is being handled poorly but I just
think maybe we don't push people to
these weird limits like this especially
when they're talking about [ __ ]
sexual assault and whether or not they
sexually assaulted someone these
accusations were made the conversation
exploded on reddit and it became the
talk of the internet for a few days but
the unfortunate part about this story is
that it doesn't even come close to
ending there because online controversy
only means me
controversy on January 14th a post was
made on destiny subreddit that linked to
a ton of screenshots from genna's public
discord servers these screenshots show
more than 15 examples of Jenna allegedly
using racist transphobic anti-semitic
and homophobic language the post also
showed search results of specific racist
and homophobic slurs that were searched
in the discord in total the search
revealed more than a thousand results of
various users in the server using this
language as you might imagine the
negative reaction was immediate and
overwhelmed and Jenna actually saw the
post for the first time on stream
literally Jewish she then promptly
deleted her entire discord the news
actually grew so quickly that it reached
the front page of Reddit and people all
over Twitter we're talking about now
Jenna maintains that she doesn't
remember saying all of these things and
that makes sense because some of these
messages date as far back as 2017 but
some of them are as recent as 29 okay
I'm just gonna be really [ __ ] honest
I don't remember anything it's probably
real I don't remember any of it all
right it doesn't reflect Who I am today
I don't remember any of this while all
of this was unfolding Jenna continued
her stream and began apologizing for the
things she said in the past on disk one
I'm sorry Bernie with feelings you're
right
yeah I'm sorry that I'm a [ __ ] and I'm
sorry that I have a stupid girl and I'm
sorry that I make mistakes and I'm sorry
that I did stupid things and I'm sorry I
said stupid things and I'm sorry that
I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] like I'm supposed to
say if I'm I feel terrible I'm a [ __ ]
I don't care what I said in the past I
don't care like I don't I care but like
picked up I don't wish hate upon anyone
they never will since that stream the
nooses were picked up by a few different
internet news sites and the reaction has
continued to flood on reddit
some commenters have been asking for her
to be banned or lose her partner status
and others are just shocked by how
extreme the
languages we've included a few of the
screenshots from the incident for
context but most of them we didn't feel
comfortable putting on screen so far
we've heard no reaction from twitch or
discard regarding the incident there has
been a lot of commentary about Jenna
getting banned from twitch but the
reality is these these things didn't
happen on Twitch so I'm not actually
sure what kind of action they could take
the story is still developing and this
literally just happened so we're gonna
have to wait and see how this pans out
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit up our Instagram
Twitter and Facebook pages